you want to get your thoughts on Stephen
Amell allowing his buddy Michael
Rosenbaum to broadcast his panic attack
that he had during Michaels podcast
called inside of you yes so Stephen was
talking about how busy he's been since
wrapping arrow and then this happened
I do love I do love the fans I just
don't want any responsibility right now
other than a husband and father I really
are you gonna go see someone and you're
not gonna do that
I might think I might I wish you can go
see this guy dr. tesslar Rowan
Connecticut this old Jewish guy is it
hot in here or am I just sweating I
gotta say you are slow I am I don't know
why Hey look if you're cool with me
sweating I'll just sit here and sweat no
don't worry about it man sweating
honestly man I think I might be sick
you want to throw up yeah oh yeah I
might have to cut this short man I'm not
feeling well at all really yeah well why
don't you you leave if you want but Wow
first you drink someone I'm gonna get
you send my Tylenol no I think I just
got to go do you want me to bring it
home let me drive you home actually just
kind of want to walk to mines yeah I
just need I just need fresh air dude
come on thanks buddy yesterday is but a
couple weeks later they came back and
did the rest of the podcast and talked
about it yeah so he walked home just
like insanely cold like had the chills
and had to have a team come to his house
and give him IV so the whole thing that
you went through and you just say he's
just so rundown Nelson says why we
listen to this and like I think it's
interesting that because it wasn't live
like they record these plant faster than
they post it so he had every opportunity
to say no no don't put that out there
but he decided no no I want people to to
hear it so yeah it's interesting for him
that provoked it because once again
we've we've had these situations where
people that play superheroes and we see
them as these you know larger-than-life
people but how they go through like
struggles just like that so it's
interesting that he made that decision I
Matthew says panic attacks are no jokes
Christa's panic attacks are the same as
anxiety attacks masses Stephen is brave
to do it free to do this
sarcastic klutzes I feel bad for him
that wasn't sarcastic polishes props of
that host a great guy shows us yeah I
know how he feels but yeah it's
interesting that he was willing to